yeah we talked about elliptic curves and
how we can use them as a sort of drop-in
replacement for the mathematics in
things like diffie-hellman key exchange
and the digital signature algorithm and
so on there's another interesting story
that people are asking me to talk about
which is the story of the dual EC drbg
or the dual elliptic curve deterministic
random bit generator which is a
pseudo-random generator for generating
random numbers most of the time you do
programming you don't need something
that's truly random well if you're
writing a computer game and you need the
AI to act in a kind of unpredictable way
a normal general mathematical random
number generator but just move some bits
around and produces numbers between a
minimum and a maximum should be fine for
cryptography that is not the case
for cryptography what you need to not be
able to do is predict anything to do
with what it's going to output it needs
to be as random as you can and of course
the problem of computers is they aren't
random they don't operate in a random
way so if I produce any mathematical
function or any logic circuit that
produces something that looks random the
problem is it isn't actually random what
a normal operating system will do is
combine an actual source of randomness
so for example the decay on over
radioactive isotope or my mouse clicks
which are kind of random or my typing
which is sort of the pace of which is a
bit odd and it'll combine that actual
randomness with something that produces
a very long stream of random bits for
use by applications on a machine like
these oh these are called cryptographic
random number generators we're not
talking about the actual randomness
today we're talking about the generators
for generating these random bits but
they used all the time if you go onto if
you perform a handshake on the Internet
you're going to be generating a random
number used once you're going to be
generating the private part of a
different key exchange and so on so
these need to be unpredictable if I can
predict your private diffie-hellman key
then I can just get straight in on your
conversation that's not a good thing the
way normally a random number generator
like this works is a bit like this so we
have some kind of state which we'll call
s and that's the current internals for
our random number generator and that is
a secret now this is seeded based on
real random date
so for example the keyboard taps or the
hard disk latency and things like this
on a computer now what we do I ask this
random number generator to generate some
random bits for me and it passes this
state through a function G which is a
one-way function like a hash function
and this produces some seemingly random
bits which I can use in my application
for something secure now if I ask it to
produce G of s again it's going to be
the same thing the hash is always the
same so what happens is at this point we
pass s through another function f of s
and it comes back down here to be s plus
1 and so the state gets updated this is
in general what a random number
generator will do so we seed the random
number generator with something actually
random and we keep doing that whenever
we can but it doesn't happen all the
time and then we can update the state
and we can generate random bits as
required
now usually these are different
functions but often hash functions of
what we use the reason is because it has
to be one way what we absolutely want to
make sure is that I can't work out as an
attacker what this state is because if I
can I can predict the next random value
you're going to be that could be your
password but you're generating on your
password manager so I've seen this
output this is something you sent in the
clear let's say a random number or
something I've seen it can I calculate
what the state is well no because it to
do that I have to reverse this one-way
function this hash function so I can't
do it I'm stuck here that's the idea now
in the early two-thousands the National
Institute for Standards and technology's
in the US published a list of four new
random number generators the idea being
that these would be adopted by the kind
of key players who are actually building
these libraries like open SSL so most of
these were kind of standard like like
I'm showing you here one of them was
based on elliptic curves and was a
little bit unusual and so it kind of
piqued everyone's interest and though I
say peak devil and suspicion at the time
this was called the dual elliptic curve
drbg which I was going to call Julie C
from now on otherwise I'm going to get
very tongue-tied it works very much like
this using elliptic curves just to
remind you when we talked about elliptic
curves an elliptic curve looks a bit
like this and it has a formula of the
type Y squared is XQ
plus a X plus B the idea is that this
can be used to perform a one-way
function like our hash if we have a
point here P on our curve we can produce
a multiple of P let's say here which is
a P and if I give you that you can't
tell me what a was right that would be
solving the elliptic curve discrete log
problem very very difficult right that's
all we really need to know about the
mathematics for this particular one so
we could replace these two one-way
functions with these elliptic curve
functions this point addition and kind
of get the same kind of structure going
and the and the nice thing about it if
it worked would be that this is kind of
mathematically provable in some sense
because we know how difficult this
problem is we don't know for sure what
the difficulty of this hash function is
because no one's broken it yet right we
all fought sha-1 with unbreakable and
then what happen all right
so how does Julie C work all right so we
have our two random variables on our
curve right P thank you it doesn't
matter where they are for this example
they just points on the curve so those
each have an X and a y-coordinate we
have a state for a random number
generator s that is not a point on the
curve it's just a number so what we do
we want to use s to generate some random
bits but then we also need to update the
state and their state has to remain
secret remember so the first thing we do
is we calculate s P all right so we're
moving P around the curve s x right and
that gives us our R is just the x
coordinate of this so this is going to
be a point on the curve we take the x
coordinate and that's our number now ah
it's sort of an intermediate variable
we're going to use it to generate our
random bits so we calculate our Q and we
take the x value so our Q X in some
sense and we scrap the first 16 bits of
that we take the least significant bits
of that from 16 to the end I'm using
sort of Python notation why not write
what sort of size and in bits is that
number they're going to be approximately
256 bits because they're modulo upon
bits 256 bits and this particular curve
now this has been our random number
right so so far so good we've got some
random bits out we then use our we pass
it through P again so we say our P don't
doesn't
so why and that produces our new s but
by taking just VX again so what we've
got is the exact same framework that I
showed you at the beginning we've got a
state we update the state by moving it
around the elliptic curve a bit and
taking just the x coordinate but we also
can output some bits in principle which
is not a terrible idea for a random
number generator
except for actually this is much slower
than a normal hash based one by about a
thousand times right which for you know
for someone who really cares about
security maybe they would be able to
accept that but in fact actually there
are some other bigger problems with this
that mean that the thousand times is
really the good part of the deal in SATs
in some sense remember that the whole
point of this is that if I get this in
the clear I can't reverse to find this
internal state the reason I can't do
that is because first of all I don't
know what our Q was and even if I did I
can't go backwards through this to find
R and then go this way right so we can't
reverse that because that is a one-way
function remember just because of the
elliptic curve problem if I was an
attacker how might I attack this well
the first thing is to notice is for 16
bits it's not actually very many so I
can brute-force through the possible our
Q's quite quickly to to the 16
operations 65,000 operations even on a
laptop not going to take very long so I
go through and I find all the possible
X's for this random data and only some
of them are going to adhere properly to
that elliptic curve formula where we can
find an actual Y that goes with them all
right so let's say we go from 65,000 to
10 we have 10 candidates that's a real
problem so we found that our Q fat alone
wouldn't actually be much of a problem
so then the question becomes can we
reverse this discrete log problem and
find our way into this state which would
be a huge issue and the answer is if
these two a random no we can't do that
all right if P and Q are truly random we
have to brute force it we have to start
with as one doesn't work ours too
doesn't work and how many how many of
those are there 256 bits worth which is
not yeah it gets a bit more complicated
that not all point to valid on the curve
and so on but is a lot of them now what
if there was a secret mathematical
relationship between
would that change anything what if he
was actually equal to some multiple of
hue like this now it will be very
difficult to prove that because if we
can't solve that problem we'd have to
find that a by brute force ago or there
is a relationship between the two
brilliant right we don't know but the
problem was that when this standard came
out it was implied that the NSA were the
ones that generated these points and
they did not explain how they did it you
remember the video on nothing up my
sleeve numbers let's pick a number at
random I don't know 24 and then did some
trick with it you think well that's
great but clearly 24 wasn't random
there's something up the sleeve we're
not sure about it if this is true if
there's a secret e which we can multiply
by Q to get to P then here's what
happens we have our Q because we've
derived it from bith here all right we
can calculate e our secret e times our
cue it's associative so it's actually
our times EQ EQ is P so we've got R of P
which is this and we've calculated the
internal state right this should be
impossible to go backwards from here to
get to here it's trivial if we know this
secretly right which is kind of worrying
what's more interesting about this it's
not so much the mathematical backdoor
but could exist
it's wherever it exists no one knows and
what happened when this NIST standard
was announced so when it was announced
cryptographers said well first of all
this is not enough bits you're cutting
off here right there's a slight bias in
the output we don't like it it doesn't
look random enough that's a problem it's
a thousand times slower that's a problem
all right this didn't worry too much
about this they said it's fine
why we're gonna put it in then in 2007
dan sumo and Niels Ferguson from
Microsoft did a short talk explaining
that this backdoor could exist you know
that should have killed this off
straight away but the problem was but it
was an agreed standard in this it was
starting to be implemented in some of
these libraries and that's deeply
concerning we don't know whether this
exists hypothetically it could all right
but no one can find this e so how can we
know but then the Snowden leaks came
along and it looks even more suspicious
money was changing hands between the NSA
in companies to have them install this
as their star
for a number generation that's deeply
suspicious and so the strong opinion
should he be consensus of the
cryptographic community is that this is
indeed a backdoor someone knows that a
but it isn't me and but we don't know
for sure but it's a really interesting
issue because there could be a backdoor
but they might not now of course when
you're using this you can generate your
own P&Q and then it's not it hasn't got
a backdoor well if you put it in
yourself but the interesting thing was
in my list standard they said you have
to use this P and Q if you don't we
won't give you a fits accreditation for
being extra secure which is also
suspicious so it's a really interesting
read if you read the history of this
people were coming up with problems they
were publishing papers saying that's not
right and they were being ignored and
the standard was put through anyway
which is you know very interesting if I
was on stage I don't do magic right but
if I was on stage and I said to you
let's pick a number at random I don't
know 24 and then did some trick with it
you think well that's great but clearly
24 wasn't mathematics to do with lines
and the tangent of this curve it's
actually not very complicated the point
is of what we're doing is by multiplying
G by both numbers or adding it to itself
this point addition we're moving around
this curve